okay please state your name one more
time are we really doing this again it's
like the fifth time that's a lie it's
only the fourth time
no
okay my bad continue I'm Sophia Bunsen I
haven't talked to my husband in eight
years
this is Nate Dexter he was friends with
my husband I didn't know he was dead you
think my husband killed him but I
guarantee that's impossible
okay good
but not good enough let's do it again
Jake what's going on with you she passed
the test like five times or maybe she's
in cahoots with him hmm are you two
cahooting are you kahooting okay it's
open man we had to leave now it's dead
it happens no if it's not her and it's
not him which I'm still not convinced of
by the way then it's Gotta Be The
Machine strap me Insurgent I'm taking
this thing for a test drive of truth I'm
telling you this machine is broken ask
me a question is Jay-Z really your
favorite artist yes obviously lie see
it's busted is it or is your favorite
artist really Taylor Swift
oh lie all right fine she is
she makes me feel things she makes all
of us feel things
look
that machine is working just fine why
are you being so crazy about this case I
wanted to work the toughest case we had
why because it would feel awesome to
solve it because a real man doesn't run
from a challenge I mean do they run from
the Bulls in Pamplona yeah that's the
whole point of it seriously that seems
to seem lame I don't know why you want
to spend the entire weekend at work but
I'm going home to my family see you
tomorrow Jake
fine abandon me I don't want you here
anyway
that's a lie come on man
do something with your damn Paws whoa
whoa Sarge relax
I think he might be overreacting a
little to this prank and I should know
you probably won't believe this but
I was bullied in high school for being
too handsome I don't believe you you're
right it was for setting my crotch on
fire in shop class hurt like the Dickens
point is haters gone hate Shake It Off
Taylor Swift always right the reason
bullies get to me is because I lived
with one my dad he was a cool man who
didn't like his life and he took it out
on me okay
okay now we're getting somewhere if
you're having Dad problems that's my jam
son real weird take on my crappy father
you know how I turned the corner with my
dad I stood up to him and that's what
you need to do with your dad bad no he
died in 1988. okay well that probably
won't work then but it doesn't mean you
can't go over to the 6'5 and stand up to
those bullies it'll just make fun of me
more what are you talking about Terry
you are a human Mountain you have more
muscles in your ears than I have in my
entire body never skip ear day Jake you
can Crush metal with your bare hands you
can lift a city bus you can make your
boobies Do That Bouncy thing they're
called Peck same thing now get on over
on the 6'5 and make those big jerks take
back that tiny kitten yeah all right I'm
doing it
we're gonna get out of Florida
I don't know what you're so excited
about we have a dangerous task ahead of
us wait I thought you said we didn't
need backup are you worried do we need
to call the 99 no no no no no no we have
the drop on figures we're fully armed up
and we have plenty of time to lay a trap
well okay then see you around Coral
Palms adios constant pool of sweat in my
taint you do one Greg all right see you
never drive through Vape station adios
weird Juggalo encampment bye-bye it's
slightly excused stop sign what rule
come on for running a stop sign we just
passed someone driving with both feet
out the window just be cool Larry
gentlemen I am going to need to see your
license and registration yeah whoa hold
on what do we got going on back there
oh uh yesterday's newspaper no no I'm
talking about the pile of guns in the
bucket of bullets
sure sure I made you about to step out
of the vehicle yeah it'd be weird if you
didn't
this is a little bit weird never been
arrested before I mean I was detained
once by Taylor Swift's security team but
that was a misunderstanding
we got to get out of here
figures could show up at any minute
don't worry we can't outsmart some small
town sheriff we're in my PD detectives
we got this on a Sam iced tea plays this
on TV we keep the Tony safe hey fellas
listen I am sorry about the delay we are
overwhelmed here today
we hired our first woman so of course
you need your own bathroom and the shirt
don't fit right all things chaos it's
not a problem Sheriff
you have nothing to worry about
so uh what are you doing out here
sneaking a cigarette
just can't quit but you knew that didn't
you page 136 what is that strange book
you're holding I've never seen it before
Jake Peralta's guide to tricking Amy's
dad what who put that there why did I
use the title page relax Jake it's okay
actually I'm quite impressed you are
well you did a ton of research here you
made a binder this is real Santiago
stuff yeah I I guess it is I even use
tabs the good ones yes there are good
and bad types of tabs that's something
we all know I can't believe you did all
this you got my family tree all of my
case files a lot of photos yes and might
I add your ponytail in the 90s puts
Amy's to shame they used to call me the
line wow cool nickname they call me the
Barracuda well I call me that I'm hoping
it catches on I was wondering what you
thought about one of my cases uh
first Essex Bank Heist yes I read that
one they got robbed the day before their
grand opening I never saw that one
that bothered me for 20 years but I see
that you wrote a note here that says
contractor did it comma so obvious oh
what well you know us Millennials we're
always exaggerating but what I think
happened there is is that I was reading
that file and I noticed that the
contractor Russo was the um obvious
obvious suspect but only in the sense
that he was the only one who could have
possibly done it because he had the
blueprint I talked to Russo he had an
Alabama of course of course
but you know the name of the company was
Russo and son so
I figured probably maybe definitely the
Suns did it maybe probably for sure son
oh my God this signs I think you might
be onto something really I don't know
how I missed that I bet they still live
here in New York we should go talk to
them right now I mean if that would be
okay okay are you kidding me I would
love to work a case with you that's
amazing looks like the lion is Gonna
Roar again and the Barracuda is gonna
what
anyway you get it let's go
I was counting on it bust out those
banging Bar Mitzvah beats bro
CK Kendrick Lamar Meek Mill really a lot
of Taylor Swift I'm over her I barely
even memorized all the lyrics to
Folklore what's saf3 I'm glad you asked
man for air that track is sexy ass
surprise number three okay so I know
this audio engineer who's friends with a
guy who's roommates with a guy who gets
lunch for a guy who's friends with a guy
who knows Drake and he laid down a beat
for us to write a song to drink like
down a beat for us what no no the friend
did the Drake thing was just to
establish his credentials and they
parked that those like six spots removed
from Drake here's the real deal
a tasty little tree two cool dudes
making sandals for your feet what I was
going for the rhyme but now I kind of
feel like it's a good idea love it
making sandals that last is our ideology
Made Real by our patented strapless
technology it's magnets oh okay yo you
can wear him on the beach wear them on a
hike wear them on a Peloton exercise
bike Doug and Jake
all right
that was crazy you never even rehearsed
it just did it perfectly it was like
Jackson made an alley I call Ally ah I
wanted Ally